♪♪
.
>> Sean: OH HERE'S OUR VIDEO OF
THE DAY, LOOK AT YOUR SCREEN,
RESTAURANT OWNER IN LOS ANGELES
IS BEING HAILED AS A GOOD
SAMARITAN AFTER HE TOOK DOWN A
SUSPECTED ROBBER WHO ATTACKED AN
ELDERLY MAN EARLIER THIS MONTH.
THE THIEF BELIEVED TO BE
HOMELESS TOOK THE VICTIM'S PHONE
AND WALLET IN BROAD DAYLIGHT.
WHEN RESTAURANT OWNER TIM RAD
CLIFF CHASED HIM DOWN AND HELD
HIM BEFORE POLICE ARRIVED AROUND
TEN MINUTES LATER.
NOW THE LAPD SAID THEY ARE
ADDING 200 MORE OFFICERS TO THE
HOLLYWOOD DIVISION AS CRIME
CONTINUES TO SPIRAL OUT OF
CONTROL.
MAYBE IF KAMALA HARRIS DIDN'T
PRAISE THE DEFUNDING OF THE LAPD
MAYBE WE COULD PROTECT MORE
PEOPLE.
OF COURSE IT IS ONLY THE LATEST
EXAMPLE OF FAR-LEFT POLICY
FAILURES IN MAJOR CITIES AS
RESIDENTS IN URBAN PRECINCTS ALL
ACROSS THE COUNTRY CONTINUE TO
SUFFER UNDER FAR LEFT FAILED
LEADERSHIP.
FOR EXAMPLE, OUT IN MINNEAPOLIS,
THE TEACHER'S UNION THERE HAS
REACHED A NEW AGREEMENT WHICH
STIPULATES THAT WHITE TEACHERS
ARE TO BE LAID OFF FIRST
REGARDLESS OF THEIR SENIORITY IN
WHAT APPEARS TO BE BLATANTLY
RACIST AND UNLAWFUL.
HERE WITH REEKS CLAY TRAVIS WITH
LEO 2.0 TERRELL.
LEO, TO ME THAT'S SIMPLE BASIC
FUNDAMENTAL DISCRIMINATION 101.
RACISM 101.
>> FOR 30 YEARS I'VE BEEN
FIGHTING FOR EQUALITY AS A CIVIL
RIGHTS ATTORNEY AND THAT'S
INEQUALITY.
THAT'S BACKWARDS.
YOU'RE A HUNDRED PERCENT
CORRECT.
IT'S RACIST.
IT'S DISCRIMINATORY, IT'S
ILLEGAL.
IT SHOULD BE INVALIDATED
IMMEDIATELY.
I READ WHAT THE UNION SAYS.
THEY SAID THEY WANT STUDENTS TO
HAVE TEACHERS THAT LOOK LIKE
THEM.
WRONG.
THE STUDENTS NEED TEACHERS WHO
WILL EDUCATE THEM.
EDUCATE.
NOT WHAT THEY LOOK LIKE!
IT IS INSULTING THAT PEOPLE ARE
GOING TO BE JUDGED BASED ON
COLOR AND, MORE IMPORTANTLY,
SEAN, COLOR DETERMINES
QUALIFICATIONS?
WRONG.
SKILL, TALENT, EXPERIENCE,
PROFESSIONALISM.
THIS IS BASICALLY AN EXTREME
LEFTIST SOCIALIST AGENDA ON THIS
EQUALITY CRITICAL RACE NONSENSE.
IT'S ILLEGAL AND SHOULD BE
INVALIDATED IMMEDIATELY.
>> Sean: THIS WOULD BE
INSTITUTIONALIZING RACISM, CLAY.
>> YEAH, OF COURSE IT WOULD.
AND I AGREE WITH EVERYTHING LEO
SAID.
LOOK, THE FOUNDATION OF THE
DEMOCRAT PARTY NOW IS TWO
THINGS, SEAN.
IT IS EVERYTHING IS RACIST, AND
AMERICA IS AN AWFUL PLACE.
THAT IS BASICALLY EVERYTHING
THAT THE DEMOCRATS BELIEVE, AND
IF YOU DRILL DOWN ESSENTIALLY
EVERY POLICY THAT THEY ADVOCATE
FOR, THAT'S WHAT IT IS AT ITS
ESSENCE.
IT'S WRONG.
WE'RE GOING TO SEE A SUPREME
COURT CASE THIS FALLS THAT DEALS
WITH MER TOCK CRAZE VERSUS
AFFIRMATIVE ACTION FOCUSED ON A
LARGE EXTENT ON ASIAN KIDS.
SO WHAT I SEE IS WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE BACK TOWARDS EQUALITY AND
REJECT THIS IDEA OF EQUITY WHICH
HAS TAKEN OVER.
YOU KNOW THEY DON'T TALK ABOUT
EQUALITY ANYMORE THEY TALK ABOUT
EQUITY WHICH IS A DIFFERENT
NOTION.
AND SO THE DEMOCRAT PARTY BROKEN
AT ITS CORE AND THIS IS PERFECT
EVIDENCE OF IT IN A CITY THAT
HAS BEEN RIDDEN WITH ALL SORTS
OF FLAWS ASSOCIATED WITH
ATTEMPTING TO BE AS WOKE AS THEY
POSSIBLY CAN.
>> Sean: AND, LEO, AS A LAWYER,
WHY WOULD THEY OPEN THEMSELVES
UP FOR SUCH A CLEAR, CLEAN,
DISCRIMINATION LAWSUIT THAT WILL
COST THEM TENS OF MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS?
>> BECAUSE THEY DON'T CARE.
LOGIC IS OUT THE WINDOW.
THEY ARE TRYING TO -- I READ THE
ARTICLE.
THEY'RE TRYING TO MAKE THIS A
NATIONAL MODEL.
IT'S GOING TO GET STOPPED AT THE
FIRST DOORSTEP.
ONE LAST POINT SEAN IS THIS.
THE ASSUMPTION THAT PEOPLE OF
COLOR GOT SHORT CHANGED.
I HAVE A BACHELOR'S DEGREE, I
HAVE A MASTER'S DEGREE.
I HAVE A LAW DEGREE.
THE COLOR OF THE TEACHER WAS
IRRELEVANT.
IT WAS WHETHER OR NOT THAT
TEACHER WAS COMPETENT.
AND THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
I DON'T NEED TO SEE A COLOR FOR
A TEACHER.
I WANT TO SEE THE SKILL SET.
BUT IT'S INSULTING TO EVERY
AFRICAN AMERICAN OR PERSON OF
COLOR THAT YOU NEED A PERSON OF
COLOR TO TEACH YOU.
I REJECT THAT.
>> Sean: I WOULD IMAGINE A BIG
LAWSUIT.
CLAY LAST TEN SECONDS, YOURS.
>> YEAH, A HUNDRED PERCENT, I'M
WITH LEO.
I WENT TO PUBLIC SCHOOL HERE IN
NASHVILLE, I HAD PHENOMENAL
TEACHERS WHO WERE BLACK, I HAD
PHENOMENAL TEACHERS WHO WERE
WHITE.
YOU KNOW HOW MANY TIMES I
THOUGHT ABOUT THE RACE OF THE
TEACHER.
ZERO.
I THOUGHT ABOUT ARE THEY MAKING
SENSE AND MAKING ME SMARTER?
THAT'S WHAT EVERY PARENT CARES